Rogan experience,
that's where that comes from.
I mean that was just fucking tense.
Oh,
it's the,
it's the practicality to me,
right?
Like,
yes,
exactly.
We have a referee,
we have walls,
we have whatever,
you know,
fans.
It's entertaining people.
But like I need to know,
I need to know that.
Like would that be in nature,
you know,
that'd be doing whatever that be
selfdefence that'd be fucked.
US fighting over a territory or food or
whatever.
Like I need to know what would happen.
Like if we had like that's why I want
these finishes.
We only get 15 minutes to be able to
tell ourselves what would have happened
in that situation.
You know?
And when it goes to a decision,
I'm pissed because I don't know,
you know,
like you don't know,
especially these three round fights
where I'm waking up like these last
couple fights,
like late in the fight,
I'm pissed because I'm like,
I don't know if that would have been
another 30 minutes or another two hours
that we're scrapping in the woods.
Like who gets the bone?
You know?
I want to know.
And so that's,
that's crazy.
And of practicality,
and it's your survival and this is the
way I get to know myself.
That's deep.
Who gets the EU
the way you just put it.
Not only you've ever heard anybody put
it that way.
You need to know that the problem with
vegans is the problem with people.
It's not veganism,
it's people.
If you get a room that has 100 people in
it,
the odds of one of those people being a
fucking idiot is a hundred percent.
It's almost 100 percent that one of them
is a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
So if you get $300,
million people,
you have 3 million fucking idiots and
some of those folks are vegans.
And that's the problem with veganism.
It's not,
it's not veganism itself.
It's there's a certain percentage of
human beings that they don't have to do
anything to become vegans,
right?
They just joined this group.
It's not like you have it.
Well,
we're,
we're thinking about allowing you in to
the Vegan culture,
but we want to know what your philosophy
is.
Are you a hateful person?
Are you a person that's looking to be a
Vegan?
So you can just talk shit about other
people,
are you looking to be and are you
looking to be in a group or a gang of
plant based Gad and put the word Vegan
in front of your name and just start
talking shit because that's a lot of the
people.
And so people read all these angry,
hateful things that these people,
right?
And they go,
oh,
well this is vegans,
but it's not.
It's not.
Most vegans are not like that at all
people.
Most people are not like that at all,
but there's a certain percentage of them
and they claimed veganism and they
usually put that name,
the word Vegan in their fucking screen
name.
That's how you can spot those assholes.
Yeah,
they're proud.
they're into it.
They're in a plant based gang.
That's really what happens.
Yeah.
And so what it is is not necessarily
even a problem of diet.
It's a problem of human nature,
is that people love to stand on the
moral high ground that will love to
point down at all the other people.
Whether it's a religious issue,
like you're not eating Halau or you're
not eating kosher or you,
you're eating meat on Good Friday,
whatever the fuck it is,
they just decide that they have this
moral high ground that you don't have,
so fuck you.
I'm doing it right.
And it really comes from our own
questions of our own existence and this
messiness that we're all inherently
aware of that life eats life.
So it's weird.
But whole life I thought I'd be scared
to death and most people we all are.
We're all terrified of fucking dying
because we don't know.
But that was the closest I ever came and
I wasn't scared.
Like suddenly the fear just went away
and it seemed logical.
Like of course it's over,
like things end and I didn't want to
die.
I wasn't,
didn't have a death wish,
but I was like,
if it's done,
it's,
it's kind of,
it's done.
And count your blessings and be happy
and don't be a bitch.
Like don't.
If,
if the fucking fairy man shows up
tonight,
don't fucking hold out.
Don't be the last asshole at the party.
Go No,
like just fucking pay the ferryman get
on a boat and go,
we'll see what's next and stuff and then
ultimately late in time did a good job
and I fucking wound up living and stuff.
So I know this much.
I got to read a bunch of shit like after
I nearly died and it was all nice.
People wrote very nice things about me
and shit and I expected,
you know,
creature of the Internet that some
people be like I wish he had fucking
died.
Fuck them to death and shit.
I wish he'd stay silent.
But generally it was like very nice
things.
People were kind of positive and stuff.
So I was like fuck man.
Like
you know,
again,
I didn't want to die but like if I had
like that would've been okay.
Now I'm back at it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like now until it ends like I've got a,
you know,
and it's Kinda easy as long as they
don't wake up with a fucking dead girl
are alive.
Boy,
I don't think like they'll fucking broke
me over the coals when I die in the
future and shit like that.
But it felt weird to be so close to the
completion.
And so having something that normally
terrifies you suddenly be like,
oh,
it's okay.
Like I don't know if you walked up and
put a gun in my face,
I'm sure I'd feel threatened,
but like I kind of lost my fear of
death.
I'm not like death defying.
I won't go out and do anything
differently,
but that,
that dark cloud that kind of kills any
good time.
The moment you start thinking about like
the fear and anxiety you're going to die
one day,
like you know it's gone and now all of a
sudden I'm like,
yeah,
I'm going to die one day and it's going
to be awesome,
but not for the reasons that you think.
I'm saying it's going to be awesome.
Just be awesome.
Because a finish like it's nice to
finish things.
We know how good it feels in life to
complete something and that's the
biggest fucking thing in life you'll
ever complete is your journey.
So I didn't walk away going like I got
to do more.
Like I got to fucking live life to the
fullest.
I just got to keep doing what I've been
doing.
Like living life the way I enjoy it,
trying to do things.
Sometimes they work,
sometimes I fail and Shit.
Sometimes people are on your side.
Sometimes people like you fucking blow
and just do that fucking time.
Have good conversations in the process.
Meet interesting people here,
new points
of view and shit like that and keep at
it.
But it's nothing to be afraid of.
From my perspective.
They were just calling me more name said
trying to set up straw men.
And is this egyptologist who is in that
documentary who dismissed everything was
still around.
Oh yeah.
And has he amended his position at all?
Not to my knowledge.
I haven't spoken with him for years and
years and years.
Did you ever speak with them off the
record or personally alone?
What is this?
Oh,
I'll tell you this,
but he didn't say this off the record
house.
I guess it was off the record.
I don't think I will shut this years
ago,
but I'll say it now at that debate,
at that debate,
AAA's debate.
He,
I just suddenly found myself in the hall
with him and there was no one else
around so he could totally deny this.
But it's true.
My perspective,
at least he,
um,
said something to me like,
you know,
you don't really believe this.
I know you don't really believe this.
You just won't be on television and,
you know,
be famous or something like that.
He said,
I said,
no,
I really do believe it.
Or you know,
I really go by the evidence and I do
think the evidence says this.
And he served was telling me that,
no,
you don't,
you know,
he was like,
I dunno.
I analyze what the sizing you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then he slept in and then,
and then what he does is he starts
asking me a question of some detailed
question about the geology and well,
if that's the case,
how can such and such and I think in
hindsight might have been fed to them by
some geo archeologists just say call
someone who does archeology but knows a
little geology.
Uh,
and I,
I realize in hindsight it was meant to
be one of those Gotcha questions.
I guess they say nowadays where I
wouldn't be able to answer it,
but no,
I had,
of course I'd thought about it.
It was to me as a geologist,
very obvious.
So I start giving him this detailed
explanation as to why that's not the
case and why,
you know,
my evidence stands up,
blah,
blah blah.
And we're standing there face to face.
I'm explained this to her and I see his
face turn and it goes blank and I'm in
midsentence.
He just turns around and walks away.
He's the one who realized he couldn't,
he couldn't refute what you were saying.
Refute what I was saying.
And he wasn't really answered.
My takeaway is that he wasn't interested
in discussing it rationally or aunts,
you know,
he just went to win the debate or
whatever.
He
but,
so,
um,
when,
when Charlie and I met and I,
like I told him what my plan to sort of
help black America and wake them up
because they understood how we had
fallen victim to this brainwash,
brainwash,
the leftist dogma.
There's this idea that because we're
black,
we have to vote Democrat and anybody
that is not a Democrat is racist and
against helping us.
That is what so black Americans believe.
I believed it.
You know what I mean?
So,
and I'm a,
I'm a pretty smart girl,
you know,
I've always been a very smart girl.
I've always,
I've always been,
you know,
I've excelled in,
in academics,
right?
So how did I fall victim to it?
The exact same system,
right?
These three verticals,
the first being the family,
that breakdown of the family.
The second one I'm being culture,
which then to me like growing up it was
like Jay z,
Jay z was God to me.
Like I would throw on,
like I was,
you know,
I went through a lot of stuff when I was
a kid.
I didn't have a great family,
um,
you know,
but I would throw on a Jay z album and
like whatever he said,
it was like,
it was like going to church,
you know,
and then,
and I can't stand them now,
but the third vertical,
no,
because he knows exactly what he's doing
and he's a trader,
but third vertical being education,
which was casual side trader.
Yeah.
It's like,
like beyonce because he knows what's
happening to black America and he's
somebody that built his entire career
off the backs of black America,
you know,
of being.
The guy who started in the honing in,
in,
you know,
queens and worked at it was a drug
dealer and worked his way up and it
became the io for so many people in
Black America.
And then he stands on stage and endorses
Hillary Clinton.
He stands on stage and tell us black
America to put the same people in the
White House that locked up more black
men than any present history of United
States.
Bill Clinton,
right.
The person that stands on the crime bill
of 94 is Bill Clinton.
But because Jay Z is now focused on
getting a piece of the pie,
the globalist piece of the Pie,
he doesn't care about black America.
Um,
that's,
that's my opinion.
Um,
so what do you think that maybe he
thought the Donald Trump represented a
lot of racist white people?
No.
Oh God,
no.
Not even.
Kind of.
Not,
not for a single second,
Jason,
because Jason is very smart.
Just speak to him.
No,
I didn't speak to him.
I just,
I know there's a certain thing where
like,
I just,
I know that Jay z and beyonce betrayed
the black community.
Like there they are.
I think they did it purposely for
financial gain.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I think that they,
they,
they were interested in having,
they want to be the people that control
the world and they felt that Hillary
Clinton,
you know,
they were working with Obama very
closely and very clearly.
Now we know that the Obama
administration worked very hard to get
Hillary Clinton to office and they
wanted to stay in that group,
and so they supported Hillary Clinton
who was selected behind closed doors.
Forget the American people to be the
next president.
United States.
Yeah.